[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7,8
loisirs à vis de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro le sommaire de ce jeudi
16 mai le marché européen de saint
germain en laye a lieu ce week-end pour
la première fois une exposition est mise
en place en parallèle elle est consacrée
à la bd et nous irons y faire un tour
15e édition également pour la nuit
européenne des musées
de nombreux établissements participent
dans les yvelines la directrice du musée
de la toile de jouy qui sera avec nous
en plateau une dizaine d' équipes de
toute la france va s'affronter ce week
end à elancourt dans une discipline peu
connue
la savate forme un mélange entre box et
fitness ce n'est ce que nous
découvrirons pour la 15e édition de son
marché européen la ville de saint
germain en laye a décidé de créer une
exposition était le thème de la bande
dessinée qui étaient retenus
reportage milieu des personnages
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après leur épique match de rugby dans
l'album d'astérix chez les bretons les
irréductibles gaulois s'installe à
l'espace vers a de saint-germain-en-laye
au milieu de leurs confrères européens
j'appelais exposition bande dessinée
européenne spécialement passé dans le
cas du marché européen et vous verrez
qu'il y à des auteurs belges et des
français italien portugais espagnol
je crois qu'un suisse aussi un
yougoslave
en fait il rentre en france et c'est
ainsi bilal dont nous avons nous à grave
[Musique]
entre son voyage sur la lune et sa
visite au temple du soleil
le célèbre journaliste d'hergé vous
observent et vient découvrir à vos côtés
les différentes étapes de création d'une
planche
vous voyez la liste de ses croquis il a
choisi d'ailleurs un pont qui est au
canal saint martin je soupçonne que ce
soit le fond ou dans un film d'époque
il y avait là l'actrice qui disait
atmosphère atmosphère
je suppose que ce pont qui l'a choisi et
là vous voyez déjà le travail d'encre de
chine
la précision est pour arriver à la fin à
la plage aux couleurs plus de 75 pièces
sont exposées des planches originales
des ouvrages dédicacés et des sculptures
et maquettes classés par thématique
l'exposition débute avec un hommage à
didier savard dessinateur de la commune
décédé il ya trois ans j'ai contacté la
famille de didier savard qui a accepté
nous le prêter les planches originales
un collectionneur aussi privé de la main
nous a prêtés notamment ce livre
dédicacé par 10 des savarts réalisé avec
l'aide de la librairie la marque jaune
et d'un collectionneur sans jama noah
l'exposition la bande dessinée
européenne présente ses trésors jusqu'au
23 mai quant au marché européen ce
samedi 18 mai sur les places du marché
neuf et de la victoire une cinquantaine
de stands vous attendent ainsi que des
animations et son traditionnel village
des enfants
nouveauté cette année c'est large et aux
adolescents avec un grand stand
tatouages éphémères
un mur d'escaladé un jeu sur portable
le soir c'est la nuit européenne des
musées l'exposition restera ouverte en
nocturne et de nombreux établissements
yvelinois sont engagés dans cette 15e
édition du jeu de l'oie au musée
d'archéologie nationale de saint germain
en laye à l'atelier photo ojlt embolie
train la programmation est riche
vous pouvez retrouver plus
d'informations concernant le musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines et le
palais du roi de rome à rambouillet dans
le replay du 7-8 culture du mardi 14 mai
enfin n'oubliez pas de faire un tour sur
le site internet officiel pour garder
toute la programmation
[Musique]
le musée de la toile de jouy situé au
château de l'églantine à jouy en josas
aussi fait sa nocturne avec nous en
plateau charlotte duvivier lebrun
bonjour bonjour alors que sera-t-il
possible de faire samedi soir pour cette
nuit des musées alors samedi soir
effectivement le la nuit des musées
s'est inscrit pour nous dans un week-end
qui est important puisque c'est le
marché d'églantine au musée donc
vendredi samedi et dimanche
nous exposons
nos nouvelles collections le musée
développe de nombreux produits autour de
la toile de jouy et on lance nos
collections dans tout le rez de chaussée
est investi par notre boutique et le
samedi soir
nous organisons un certain nombre
d'animations des ateliers pour les
familles qui seront cette année dé
fabrication de lanternes japonaise
puisque actuellement nous accueillons
une exposition sur les sarrazac y sont
des toiles de imprimés japonaise et nous
allons ensuite proposé aux familles ou à
ceux qui arriveront un peu plus tard de
venir visiter cette ce parcours à la
lueur des lanternes qui auront été
fabriqués à partir de 20 heures
voilà et en même temps sur le parvis du
musée
il y aura un fou trucks qui proposera
des menus asiatique pour être dans la
thématique
alors ça c'est pour le samedi soir mais
le marché les glandes in vous nous avez
parlé c'est du vendredi au dimanche
d'actes mans vendredi toute la journée
jusqu'à 19 heures samedi de nouveau à
partir de 10 heures et jusqu'à 22 heures
puisque le musée fermera à 22 heures et
le dimanche de nouveau 10 heures 19
heures toute la journée et avec une
animation supplémentaire le dimanche
puisqu'on pourra visiter
le musée avec une conférencière à 15
heures
c'est une visite guidée gratuite à
l'occasion de ce marché d'églantine
c'est un marché qui a lieu tous les ans
pour présenter les nouvelles collections
qu'ils sont elles ces nouvelles
collections vous avez parlé d'une
exposition en lien avec le japon oui
tout à fait en fait on décline
énormément de produits à partir de la
toile de jouy ongrais un prime
on fait réimprimer un certain nombre de
motifs issus de nos archives et on les
décline
sur énormément de produits ça va de
cette année on a des baskets des montres
des dés la papeterie beaucoup de
maroquinerie des sacs
voilà des quelques petits articles pour
les enfants de des arts de la table
enfin voilà tout ce qui la toile de jouy
se prêtent à énormément d utilisation et
puis on a aussi l'occasion de créer des
collaborations avec des grandes maisons
type armor lux mineurs qui naissent pour
les chaussures et on présente aussi à
l'occasion de ce marché
ces nouveautés quelle est la suite pour
le musée la toile de jouy la suite pour
le musée la théologie donc nous allons
terminer cette exposition d'abord japon
et jouit
le 23 juin et puis le 21 juin nous avons
une nouvelle donc quelques jours avant
les deux expositions vont se croiser
nous avons une exposition qui s'appelle
art texture cette année c'est la dixième
édition
c'est une exposition de créations
textiles contemporaines
c'est une sélection qui est fait par une
association qui s'appelle france
patchwork et qui montre un petit peu les
longs et la créativité dans le domaine
du textile en france essentiellement on
les accueille tous les deux ans et c'est
la 10e édition donc c'est un peu un
anniversaire cette année et nous les
accueillons jusqu'au 1er septembre
et puis nous sommes en train de
travailler préparé une très belle
exposition qui commencera le 8 octobre
sur le thème de l'utilisation des
indiennes et des toiles imprimées et
particulièrement des toiles de jouy dans
la mode du xviiie à nos jours avec
notamment les très belles collections
qu'on voit apparaître en ce moment chez
les grands créateurs
très bien merci de charles olivier
lebrun est venu sur notre plateau s'est
retrouvé merci merci pour retrouver
toutes les informations sur le site
internet du musée
sortez vos nappes à carreaux et vos
paniers en osier la ville de plaisir vos
invitations pique nique géant dans le
parc du château vous retrouverez le
traditionnel atelier des senteurs petite
nouveauté cette année un atelier cuisine
anti gaspi rendez vous dimanche 19 mai
dès midi
bien connu des petits t'choupi violeur
en oublie dit sem les 18 mai au pavé du
canal il est l'un des nombreux invités
de la librairie qui fête cette année ses
trente ans après bordeaux l'année
dernière l'open national de savate forme
a lieu ce week-end à elancourt pour la
première fois dans les yvelines à partir
de 13h30 au palais des sports des
équipes de toute la france vont
s'affronter dans cette discipline mêlant
technique de boxe et fitness en une
chorégraphie de 2 minutes 30 à 3 minutes
le club de boxe française d'elancourt
maurepas a créé cette section 2014 et
plus de la moitié de ses adhérents y
participent
un stage sera également proposée au
public pour découvrir ce sport qui
compte dix mille pratiquants en france
le président du club et une adhérente
était sur le plateau du service sport
pour expliquer la discipline ça recoupe
tout l'été une bourse est donc c'est
pour ça que c'est complémentaire on fait
beaucoup d'étirements
on doit donner des coups de pied
la tête quand on peut on travaille
énormément il faut imaginer un cours
d'une heure et demie pendant lesquelles
vous avez faire que sautiller et vous
battre c'est vrai que quand on pratique
cette discipline
on se concentre vraiment pour apprendre
la chorégraphie bien faire notre
technique ce qui nous permet vraiment de
évacuer tout ce qu'on a vécu durant la
journée est vraiment que penser à cette
chorégraphie qu'on a à faire et à cette
technique qu'on doit avoir ce n'est pas
vraiment d'évacuer voilà tout le stress
tout ce qu'on a pu ressentir
on est vraiment focalisé par une
araignée sur ce qu'on fait et ce qu'on
pratique et c'est un week-end 13 parties
qui vous attend à versailles avec la 10e
édition du triathlon quatre parcours
différents le du match on familiale en
duo le triathlon des suisses et le swing
run le samedi le dimanche les grands
triathlon du roi et de la reine les
inscriptions sont fermés mais vous
pouvez venir encourager les coureurs
plus insolite le modélisme maurepas club
organise sa première course de voitures
radiocommandées de l'année ce dimanche
au village était d'oise here avec ou
sans bolide vous pouvez y assister
l'entrée est gratuite on sort des
yvelines pour explorer le grand bleu il
reprend il recouvre 70% de la surface de
notre planète et nous les mettons en
danger les océans ont droit à leur
exposition à la fondation goodplanet
l'occasion de sensibiliser le public sur
la préservation de l'environnement
reportage de paul bullock et de nos
confrères la grand parent est fascinant
grands mais aussi fragile les océans qui
recouvrent aujourd'hui 70% de la surface
de notre planète font l'objet de la
nouvelle exposition de la fondation
goodplanet dans son domaine de longchamp
la fondation présidée par yann arthus
bertrand se sert de l'art et la culture
pour sensibiliser le public à
l'environnement
planet océan a donc un double objectif
exposition à la fois artistique et
pédagogique c'est vraiment la halle axes
de travail à la fois yann arthus
bertrand et l' axe de travail de
l'information en elle même c'est de
sensibiliser le grand public par de
belles choses par de belles expositions
et par des expériences positives
évidemment les gens qui sont
sensibilisés au sujet pourront
approfondir la question avec différents
intervenants et des médiateurs qui leur
expliqueront comment prendre soin de
l'océan comment limiter notre pollution
comment adopter une attitude zéro
déchets au quotidien puisque 80% de la
pollution des océans provient de la
terre les pieds des gens qui ne s'y
connaissent pas encore quand envie de
venir visiter en famille y trouveront
aussi leur compte puisque tout est
extrêmement accessible y compris pour
les cultures installés sur deux étages
dans le château l'exposition jeu sur
deux supports photo et vidéo
le tout est complété par une
scénographie très informative et
pédagogique avec toujours ce rôle de
sensibilisation la good planet a voulu
aller encore plus loin en faisant de
planet océan un rendez-vous immersif la
fondation tara nous a offert un
magnifique voyage au coeur du corail en
réalité virtuelle de magnifiques photos
de reproduction de baleines en polynésie
de chasse à la sardine par les espadons
jacques perrin et jacques cluzaud nous
ont confié leurs films le peuple des
océans qui sont diffusées en continu à
la fondation on a aussi une super
installation sur le plancton qui
souhaitent un ensemble d'organismes
connaît assez peu qui sont faites les
organismes marins qui subissent les
courants et qui ne peuvent pas lutter
contre et qui constitue la base de la
chaîne alimentaire de beaucoup d'animaux
et qui sont en première ligne face au
changement climatique face à la
pollution et grâce à cette installation
les gens peuvent découvrir ce que c'est
plongez au coeur du plancton idéal
planète océan est à découvrir jusqu'au
15 décembre prochain
et c'est la fin de votre cette ut
choisiront le rappel principal événement
ce week end la nuit européenne des
musées samedi soir le 19 mai ou pour
retrouver toutes les informations sur le
site nuit des musées point groove bonne
semaine dans bonne semaine sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh